merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à madame catherine vautrin merci
monsieur le président préserver notre
patrimoine le mettre en valeur et
clairement une mission essentielle qu'il
convient pour autant d'articuler avec
l'attractivité économique de nos
territoires surtout quand on compte un
million deux cent mille chômeurs en plus
depuis 2012 alors accompagner les
entreprises dans leur développement
c'est un impératif quotidien pour nos
collectivités
nous le savons tous le temps de la
négociation le temps de la compétition
est long mais celui de l'installation
des entreprises est toujours compter les
aime
malheureusement les délais d'aménagement
sont très souvent incompatibles avec les
délais de diagnostic de l'inrap
deux solutions s'offrent alors aux
collectivités soit attendre l'inrap et
perdre le prospect soit créé son propre
service c'est ce que nous avons fait à
reims
malheureusement le texte création
architecture patrimoine menace très
gravement nos services archéologie en
transformant la redevance payée par les
entreprises pour ce diagnostic aux
collectivités en une subvention payés
par l'état a posteriori bien sûr au
mépris de l'emploi mais surtout au
mépris des personnels de nos services et
finalement au mieux les collectivités
seront les trésoriers puisque payer a
posteriori ou quelquefois payeur car
malheureusement le compte n'y est pas
quand on regarde votre budget madame la
ministre
on se rend compte qu'au titre du plf
2010 est sur 81 millions d'euros prévus
71 millions sont fléchés vers l'inrap et
seulement 10 millions vers les
collectivités
cherchez l'erreur c'est en fait une
renationalisation du diagnostic pour
sauver l'inrap sur le dos des
collectivités au mépris des besoins des
entreprises
en un mot comment tuer ce qui fonctionne
alors madame la ministre
votre collègue votre voisine des
mystiques vous l'a dit en politique on
design
son veau à graulhet canada d'oubli
audrey azoulay ministre de la culture et
de la communication merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée vautrin la
question que vous me posez a fait
l'objet d'un débat intense sur ces mêmes
bancs lors de l'examen en première et en
seconde lecture de la loi relative à la
création à l'architecturé au patrimoine
une loi qui vous en rappeler a été
adopté finalement en commission mixte
paritaire ce dont je me réjouis
sur ce point particulier s'agissant
s'agissant de l'inrap et de des
diagnostics et les fouilles préventives
la réforme qui avait été menée en 2003
avait été effectué de façon je crois
légère puisque l'ouverture du marché
avait conduit à une concurrence tout à
fait déloyale entre un certain nombre
d'entreprises privées sur ce sujet de
l'archéologie préventive des diagnostics
et des fouilles et l'inrap
nous ne sommes pas revenus sur cette
ouverture du marché
en revanche que nous avons prévu ce que
nous avons fait dans la loi c'est de
normaliser ses conditions d'ouverture
c'est plusieurs choses la première c'est
de réaffirmer le rôle de contrôle
scientifique de l'état sur l'ensemble
des opérations de diagnostic et de
fouilles
ce qui n'était plus le cas dans le
dispositif législatif que vous aviez les
gays la deuxième c'est d'assurer le
financement de ce diagnostic et de ces
fouilles par une budgétisation de
l'inrap
c'est ce qui a été fait dans le projet
de loi de finances depuis l'année
dernière et encore de nouveau cette
année
enfin dernière chose c'est la façon dont
sont alloués les financements entre les
collectivités locales qui ce qu'ils ont
ces départements en matière
d'archéologie préventive entre les
collectivités locales et l'inrap
cela a été fait avec l'accord et la
consultation des organismes qui sont
prévus à cet effet donc voilà nous avons
rétabli un peu d'équité et d'équilibré
sur cet élément important de notre
politique patrimoniale